sometimes I post these online I'm like
this would be fun this I would be
murdered I would like everyone here to
think of a word or a topic or a phrase
that you'd like a rap about but there's
some listen wait wait wait did you shout
Mexicans
I should ask are you a Mexican
uh can you confirm okay cool because
again I'm not cultured enough to know
whether you could be a Colombian
pretending I don't know
I know nothing about this continent you
have an ID to prove it all right I mean
you can be in this country I don't care
I'm not gonna be like
Hmm this doesn't look legal
this looks like it's been dragged
through a river on a border
I'm an immigrant as well isn't it funny
when I say that like like I'm an
immigrant
um okay so you re you didn't even wait
because there's rules usually I'm like
hey don't suggest food or animals
because they're easy to wrap up don't
suggest anything obvious or boring
because it's tedious be creative and you
were just like nah make Mexicans just
like
all right the one thing I know about
Mexico is your flag because the the flag
of my country is terrible because it's
the Union Jack it's just like blue and
red and white the American flag's pretty
[__] cool because the Stars and
Stripes stuff and then the Mexican flag
is the green white and red and then it's
a cactus with an eagle eating a snake
which is the most [__] metal flag
ever
it's also terrifying and that's why we
should build a wall That's why because
they are heathens
you look at that flag that's not a
that's not the Canadian flag they got a
leaf a little leaf that's what they are
[__] [__] Mexican this pussy's
flag
let's see we're coming in to eat your
snakes Okay so one of the topics is
Mexicans and look if I I because I can't
control why are you showing me because
this is Mexican beer as a Mexican you
surely cannot take pride in Corona beer
this is
does that mean no better beer what does
that mean the best beer that's lying
isn't it lying people
as far as I'm aware my country never
invaded Mexico so this is acceptable for
me to say good
um
okay that's that's topic number one
let's speed this up a bit and don't you
don't [__] start over there
are you that was in Australia that was
an Australian accent wasn't it you're
from New Zealand okay
um
while it may be acceptable let me just
say the New Zealand accent especially
saying the word acceptable is so funny
because they they can't say their ease
they say they're easers eyes so could
you say I slipped on the floor
it's [__] weird
Okay Taylor you you were coming up with
Colin I was like I'm just gonna rap out
New Zealand
um whatever Mexicans no more
nationalities if anyone shouts out
Haitian
okay there's what are you saying
South Africa what is this why is this
happening Chris rap about countries okay
so do you want to throw in any more
we've got New Zealand did you just what
did you say
you're not Indian
are we you are [__] now we can't do
this right
South Africa New Zealand Mexico and
India does anyone want to say a country
that I can punch up at or something yeah
the Democratic Republic of the Congo
Chris
there is not many no you shut the [__]
up now
there's there's other this is other
people's tasks you're stealing their
jobs that's what's happening
some of you genuinely like that
[Laughter]
you know sometimes I post these online
I'm like this would be fun this I would
be murdered
except in England they would make me a
knight for this
oh like he's going over there okay
so what were you sharing at the back
[Applause]
so did you say Canada
I'll take that okay
no I want a white country
sorry South Africa right um
[Applause]
I do not condone anything that is about
to come out my mouth
if you don't like it blame him for
starting this
uh banned I mean you you make the music
if you you do whatever you want and I'll
make the wrap and it will be [__]
hell you're putting steel pan in there
red just to make it wrap out the West
Indies as well Chris while you're at it
okay we've got New Zealand we've got
Canada Mexico India and they're here and
South Africa
um and this is all your fault this is
all your fault
so upset okay
genuinely I want to put the microphone
back in there and [__] off I wanna I
wanna blue ball the [__] out of this gig
but let's do it nice
starting off freestyle like let's go
south the board to one chap say in
Mexico start it off sir you're out of
order he was like Chris rap about the
wall and the Border people coming
through smuggling in truck you know
these coyotes they're getting it up the
cash I mean exploiting taking all the
cash extortion I'm so glad that you
asked say some stereotypes what they're
lazy now that's weird man it's [__]
crazy because lately I see Mexicans
leaning on the wall in my neighborhood
outside of the U-Haul you can hire them
they'll do the job for Less give them 20
bucks they're like Caesar yes I only
know the one language and I go there
he's like Chris Ryan belt Corona okay
respect you later
it's extra made by Modelo you know they
Beyond in the market over here ah let's
[__] start it get into you lady who's
shout in India apologies yeah your
economy got thinner when we arrived used
to be top of the charts used to be so
incredible oh my God but then the
British people they came and they
plundered it was horrible what they did
the scum there they're like oh yes we'll
cut through like butter let's do things
over here in Calcutta and Bombay not the
name anymore now it's Mumbai anyway on
the Delhi Shore I'd be pretty sure you'd
be coming back soon you'll drop a bomb
on Britain it'll go boom and that will
be thoroughly deserved for what we did
but still trains Cricket entertaining
kids is that okay if we do that I'll rap
for you Chris tackle Seth Africa all
right
[__] hell I cried let's talk about
apartheid they separated the blacks from
the whites and maybe you two guys would
be like yeah that's right because you
seem to be stirring all of this [__]
like rag on the Indians just a little
bit but no it was a cause for a long
then Robert Mugabe came in like take
back the Farms and all the other things
oh it was Bloody anyway over here yeah
oh thank you buddy that's my Canadian
dude there it's not painful he's like
Chris flow slow like Maple that's the
syrup they put it on their food pancakes
mounties you know they proved riding on
the horse Green's in their hands the
only country I can disc New Zealand [__]
these guys what do you even do no one in
here is aware of you Wellington Auckland
have you heard it Christchurch no Chris
we've not observed it anyway if you're
over there it's ever so weak all you're
known for is [__] sheep and other
stuff there we go the mic I won't drop
it New Zealand [__] you you
[__] Hobbit
so